we leave tonight with an essay written
by Howard Beck from Bleacher Report I
saw a tweet from him earlier today where
he said I started crying on my keyboard
again I have a feeling it was while he
was writing this
[Music]
we remember Kobe Bryant wasn't just a
Laker
he was as magic himself said the
greatest of them all a friend a father
we see it now as Kobe plays on in
towering murals and forearm tattoos and
meticulously painted fingernails and
simple pencil sketches
[Music]
and carefully arranged flowers and
basketballs and jerseys
and altered subway signs
and changed lives
Koby was beloved unlike any other he
captured the hearts of an entire
generation
he was even introducing us to the next
one
Holmby in his daughter into building
it's the way he made us feel from even
the littlest fans to his very own
daughters
like no dreams were out of reach
like nothing was impossible
he set out to be like Mike and here we
are wanting to be like Kobe Kobe shoot
paper balls in a trashcan Kobe
he helped forge a dynasty
tore it down
builds another
that was the audacity of Kobe
inspiring and maddening
[Music]
he made us believe we too could be the
greatest we just had to put in the work
like Kobe we're gonna do it for coming
we just had to dream big like Kobe
we just had to keep going like Kobe
[Music]
so we don't just grieve
[Music]
as fans we remember the man and the
lesson
with every eight and every 24
with every tossed ball of crumpled paper
we sing his name
we channel his spirit
we silently run down the shot clock
[Music]
we remember
and we play on
you